yeah welcome to yet another oops this
was the wrong porn what no let's play
the see him yeah I feel it game black
against the skillet from the Netherlands
is there something no Paraguay there's a
little dot irony or something I think
it's the Sun in the middle without it I
think it's the Netherlands I hope I'm
doing all right iam okay i'm well
talking about the flag I set up night
off evening and thing okay I think there
is a line like that yeah not sure if it
is exactly this but let's him
I didn't play Bishop d7 maybe I should
have played
yeah my ideas all those night posts
focus on 95 to c4 together light on on
this excellent square I know that
Kasparov played this maneuver a couple
of times not sure if this is exactly a
position where he played it in but it's
quite strong for black if you manage to
really get a piece to c4 I think what
needs to take some very direct yes
something like this it's very direct
measures against that what I'm asking
myself though is what happens if I play
Knight c4 before I even take before I
even take not c4 I don't see why not
actually this piece on c4 also
controlled c6 Oh
my intention is to take on Herbie fire
he cannot take with the bishop then was
check must take with the night which is
not a big deal all taking with the night
but it's it's it and it's the difference
that the night is on c4s it controls and
covers d6 quite often white can
sacrifice a PCM getting three pawns but
I'm not sure if this is possible now if
I take here and he takes with with the
night there's no threat here I think I
can just play queen a higher factually
and where do you go now he cannot return
with the night I mean he can but it's
it's not a move and I'd be too far as
for example Oh what this I can just take
here to keep it simple
Wow white resins yeah Wow it was just
trying to figure out what to take g4 or
a three-yard this is really disastrous
best move according to computers Queen
before this is a funny move Queen before
cannot take this is easy and Bishop
takes I just take here this is plus 7 or
something yeah well it's an extra piece
and in the tech and everything yeah this
was a kind of opening disaster for what
I think something like this is it's a
valid line something along this I don't
know maybe this is this even a
theoretical position but I don't know I
don't know it's an interesting way to go
for for c4 quickly yes thanks for
watching this bye